[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to my 61
episode of dirty chance tricks if you
are looking for an antidote or
aggressive system against Joe Bauer
London opening then you come at the
right place as in this lecture not only
I'm going to show you a mini recruit on
stage but the line I have shown contain
a lot of tricks so that if your opponent
is not careful then the game can be
finished very quickly the opening arises
after the falling water d4 and it
doesn't matter whether you are Knight to
f6 or defy player let's say in this game
black plays the moon defy and after
Knight to c3 which has a clear intention
to play the movie for black needs to
stop it and accordingly Knight to f6 is
a fitting reply okay here comes the
starting point of job our London system
with Bishop to f4 and recent times this
line becomes very popular thanks to the
Grand Master Joe Baba Simon Williams and
other grandmasters who are walking on
this line and given some great ideas
from the white perspective however in
such a lines where white is relying on
piece play and blocking his C pawn are
not good and if you know your stuff very
well then
you can definitely equalize just within
the opening stage here black has many
responses but the move which I like most
is a 6 so black idea is very obvious
he wants to play Bishop to b4 pin down
the snide and then later on commence the
moon c5 well as per the current theory
there are two popular choice by white
III and night to be Phi
however Knight to be Phi is going out of
the fashion the simple reason is after
night to a6 and then later on black and
managed to play c6 which kicked this
night back to the c3 square and in all
this lines black quickly get upper hand
just within the opening stage I have
attached a model game in the PGN which
will give you a very good idea how to
handle Knight to be Phi off white there
is also a third popular choice namely a3
which stopped this Bishop coming on b4
but still this is very slow play by
white and accordingly we can respond
with a six stopping any piece intrusion
and then no matter whatever right place
black achieved this somatic break c5 and
once this happen on the ball I think it
is only black who is playing for the
advantage so considering all this aspect
by far the most popular choice is III
which is in fact the main line of Jabba
Valentin system okay no issues we are
going to play Bishop to b4 pinning down
this Knight and ready to deliver of a
foster ik on the table well Bishop to d3
is the main move however there are more
than 25 games in the database continue
with a3 which I'm afraid is not a good
move as after the following sequence
Bishop capture c3 pawn capture c3 and
now the move see fie black instantly get
better position
believe it or not but what has the only
good move in this position namely Knight
to e2 which safeguard the c3 square
however in that case his Bishop will be
locked down but more often a nod you
will see people churn out this routine
theoretical move Bishop to d3 but after
that Queen to a5 and what is going to
lose upon no matter however miracles
there are two ways what can defend the
c3 pawn and unfortunately both of them
fails the first move Knight e 2 is a
very bad move and this happens in many
quick games yup you guessed it c4 and
that poor bishop is just trapped down so
that trick you should always watch out
when white continue with Knight to e2
the more logical choice here is Queen to
d2 trying to defend this pawn but again
we have the similar kind of approach
available on the table with c4 first
attacking the bishop and once the bishop
moves anywhere let's say Bishop to e2
our knight now leaping with Knight to e4
and as I mentioned earlier white can
never save that poor c3 baby okay so
let's continue the main line with Bishop
to d3
well after that my recommendation is you
should start with c5 and again this is a
very tricky move which actually stop the
movement of g9 to come out why well
obviously he can't come to e 2 and after
this we have the familiar trick yup c4
and that poor Bishop is trap so that's
not a possibility but you may ask well
what about night
three what is wrong with that well the
same story based on the spin black and
deliver this early tactics on the ball
with first C for making this bishop very
passive and after that Knight to e4 and
yep
again the c3 problematic square for the
white camp so you can see how tricky
this line is and currently black has put
the pressure on d4 so the big question
arise how can white neutralize this
pressure there is no other option but to
give up the center and that's why D
capture C far is only logical response
in this position after that rather than
routinely capturing this pawn black
should continue with Knight B to d7 and
trying to get night on a wonderful C Phi
square now this is the third instant
where white again need to be careful as
he has to continue with Knight G to E -
however in the database there are more
than 30 games continue with Knight to f3
and the most surprising part is there is
even 2600 plus rated opponent continue
with this move which i think is a great
deal of inaccuracy and the way to
punishes you capture on c3 and when
white recaptures now you get the pawn
back with night capture c5 and if you
carefully look at this position not only
black has destroyed the White Queen side
completely and fractured this pawn
structure but on top of everything black
has a simple plan to execute namely
castle b6
Bishop to b7 and then once the rook
arrives on the see file
the backward see porn are going to fill
the heat and in fact what is really
struggling for any counter play in this
variation there are further more
problems if white continue to get rid of
one of his weaknesses for example as for
the database the majority of the games
continue with castle on the Kings side
and after we castle why try to play the
move see fall trying to liquidate his
weakness but still this doesn't walk out
as black and simply ignored this and
continue with the plan as I have
highlighted earlier with b6 the point is
after C captures defy black has this
very nice move Knight to d5 attacking
the dark squared Bishop and if black can
manage to get the dark square Bishop
then is doing fantastically Gould
because of his strong pawn structure so
nope no way white can give up this
bishop and Bishop to g3 is one of the
obvious choice so at first sight it
looks like okay white has some fracture
pawn but at least he has a bishop pair
but this is where the fun starts as
after blacks next reply Knight to c3 no
matter wherever the White Queen goes
let's say Queen - even black and play
the move Knight to e4 and get the bishop
pair and then walk on this loose
fracture porn well we have reached the
third tricky position and here if white
thinks that he can preserve this bishop
with Bishop to h4 attacking of a queen
but the matter of fact is black is
immediately winning with this deciding
tactical blow Oh
if pawn takes T 3 then Queen captures d3
and black is coming out as a clear pawn
advantage so that's not good and if
white plays the move Bishop captures
deed goes into this tactical jungle then
after the following variation Knight
captures even Bishop to e7 attacking the
rook but black has the intermediate move
Knight captures f3 check and after G
captures f3 and a move rook to e8 at the
end of the whole sequence not so
surprisingly black emerged with a clear
piece advantage so that means white has
to be very careful and again has to play
this accurate move Knight G to e2
in order not to get fracture pawn on the
Queen side and here you might think okay
now we need to get back of a pond right
well guess what not the 4th and a final
high-profile trick I want to show you in
this liners black can play this very
accurate move a6 which believe it or not
but stop white to castle on the Kings
side now before we look at it there are
few points I like to highlight here that
if you're poor and continue with a3 then
you can obviously capture this pawn and
this position is better for the black
and another move Bishop to g3 which is
recommended in many books and videos are
not good at all for the wide simple
reason is after Knight to h5 again we
have the same story where we are going
to get this bishop and then take on c5
which gives black are slightly
advantageous position I have shown this
line in the PG in with some detail
analysis so you can definitely check it
out
but the most important question is which
you are thinking from last few minutes
well how the hell on earth after playing
a six white cannot castle right well
here's the point
if white foolishly Castle here then
after the following sequence ePHI
attacking the bishop doesn't matter
wherever the bishop goes finally we can
play the moon evil and now you see the
point behind this cute move a six as we
can able to trap down this poor Bishop
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful high profile tricky
line against Jobar London system
remember at this point after the movie
three play the move Bishop to b4 and as
I have shown in the video every point it
is now white who has to play the precise
moves and even after they do that the
end results are completely favoring the
black camp thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment and I will meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care